the log of 102 the base 10 is equal to X
what is the value of x to find the
answer it's a good idea to write this in
the exponential form it can be written
as 10 raised to X is equal to 100
remember the answer to the log is the
power to which the base needs to be
raised here as the base is 10 we are
asking 10 to what power will give us 100
we know that 10 to the power 2 gives us
100 the value of x is 2
what does log of 1,000 to the base 10 is
given to us as X what will be the value
of x this can be written as 10 raised to
X is equal to 1000 and as 10 cubed is
1000 the value of x will be 3 notice
that if we take the logarithm to the
base 10 of powers of 10 we get numbers
like 2 3 4 and so on
now how does this help us in real-life
look at these numbers they range from
being tiny to huge and we do come across
such numbers in real life 110 and 1000
are commonly used this can be a person
salary this is the approximate distance
from the earth to the Sun and this is
the approximate number of cells in the
human body now assume you have been
asked to plot the following values on a
number line how would you do it we
cannot mark natural numbers like this
because these large numbers won't really
fit into our little notebooks if we mark
0 and 10 raise to 14 here these tiny
numbers like 110 and 1000 would lie
super close to 0 so what's the solution
how about we take the logarithm of the
numbers to the base 10 what will be the
log of 1 to the base 10 10 raised to 0
is equal to 1 hence we have a 0 here log
10 to the base 10 will equal 1 as 10 to
the power 1 will give us 10
log of 1,000 to the base-10 will equal
three as ten cubed is 1000 similarly we
get five eight and fourteen here now I
want you to tell me can these numbers be
easily plotted on a number line yes a
scale from zero to fourteen is enough
large numbers can be easily plotted
using logarithms also notice that there
is a very large variation between
numbers logs also help us in narrowing
down these variations so in laymen terms
we can say that if the events vary
drastically we can use logarithms and a
very common example of that is the
Richter scale which is used to measure
earthquakes uses a logarithmic scale to
understand this let's talk about the
earthquakes that happened in three
different countries in India there was
an earthquake that registered a 6.0 on
the Richter scale in the u.s. there was
an earthquake that registered 7.0 and
Japan had an earthquake that registered
a 9.0 on the Richter scale now what does
this really tell us the Richter scale is
a base 10 logarithm xscape which means
they are in the form log M to the base
10 don't worry about what this M is we
don't really want to get into details
just that log to the base 10 of
something gives us these numbers which
tell us how strong the earthquake is so
if log of M to the base 10 is 6 what
will be the value of M it will be 10
raise to 6 if log a to the base B is X
then in the exponential form B raise to
X will equal a hence 10 raise to 6 will
equal M and in these two cases M will be
10 raise to 7 and 10 raise to 9 this
will help us massively in understanding
the Richter scale the values of M tells
us how strong the earthquakes are while
the Richter scale is used just to
represent these huge numbers using a
manageable scale so an earthquake
measuring 7.0 on the Richter scale is
actually
ten times stronger than the one that
your 6.0 so while the difference between
six and seven might seem small it's not
really like that and how strong was the
Japan earthquake as compared to the one
in India it was a thousand times
stronger than the one in India and it
was 100 times stronger than the one that
occurred in the u.s. that's how
logarithmic s-- are used to measure
earthquakes
you